me showing the kids the cool stuff I can
do oh
oh that type of hyper extension for your
back is really problematic because you
have these two arteries that run on
either side of your spine on the back
portion called the vertebral arteries
and if you hyperextend you could
actually cause damage and bleeding to
one of those arteries when they actually
talk about those really rare instances
when something someone has like a stroke
post chiropractor neck adjustment it's
usually due to damage to one of these
vertebral arteries and it comes from
positioning people in hyperextension you
don't want to do that A co-worker just
called me while I'm on vacation and he
told me that he wants to change his name
to spinal column
they said well I'm busy right now I'll
just call you back
A co-worker of mine called me to say
that he wants to change his name to
spinal column
and I said I'm busy right and I'll call
you back
uh
oh so he's gonna call him back nailed it
a doctor wow baseball trick shots wait
okay
oh
what I hoped that was a wiffle ball bat
because if that was a metal bat he's
gonna have a scar
Bruce it's not a good place to get hit
you don't want to get hit in the temple
oh that's a really high dive oh my God
Is This legal
wait
what did I just watch first of all is
that real
well they were parachuting so they were
gonna parachute I guess so because if
you jump from that high even if you're
jumping into a body of water that's like
hitting cement at that height
oh my God
talk about a near Miss if that landed on
a rib definite broken rib definite
broken rib potential lung trauma
potential pneumothorax chest tube
insertion all the works I've been
getting headaches every day to the point
where ibuprofen doesn't even like help
me anymore that could be a form of a
migraine that's called an intractable
migraine where you're unable to cure it
with medications in those instances if
it's truly not breaking for a long
period of time I'm investigating
hardcore which can mean getting an MRI
brain scan who
the pill say it again
ibuprofen ibuprofen I be a who who who
are you being I ibuprofen that's kind of
funny it's ibuprofen but ibuprofen you
can't make fun of people for misstating
medical names I'm a doctor I can't say
half of them hydroxychloroquine
Hydrochlorothiazide hydroxychloroquine
hydroxy
hydroxyzine hydroxychloroquine
hydroxychloroquine
I invented this constipation unplugging
toilet the design is very human we just
need to sit on it then activate the
switch this will completely solve the
problem of constipation this looks like
a legit device from Saw 94 which I
believe is the number that they're
currently on right now I can only
imagine how much rectal bleeding will
happen if you sit on that device and I
wish I didn't have to imagine that
[Music]
oh that was a good job that's why you
always got him on their kids around pets
a lot of things can go wrong even if the
pet loves your child they could think
they're playing but they play too rough
with a child who is fragile to some
degree so I always have people asking me
they're like Catherine why do you drink
green water every day and first of all
this is not green water this is
chlorophyll water and second of all this
is like the best life hack I've ever
learned in my entire life what did I'm
gonna look this up because I'm behind on
my knowledge of chlorophyll water and by
the way I'm someone who tries to get a
plant-based products in me as often as
possible and I recommend it to people
because plant phenols are important
these are nutrients that we need so I'm
just curious what people say this does
the claim is that it improves skin helps
weight loss detoxes the body and more at
this time most of the research on
chlorophyll has been on animals or in
small human studies that lack real
evidence on its potential benefits but
let's see what our influencer friend
promises us you literally will not smell
your sweat does not smell the reason
people smell is because when they sweat
especially if they're stress sweating
the composition of their sweat is
slightly different than thermoregulating
sweat as a result the bacteria that
lives on their body that doesn't give
two if you drink chlorophyll water or
regular water consume the substance
within the sweat and then fart I feel
like when I watch these videos I only
give harsh negative criticism although
it is warranted so I'm going to say I
like this influencer shirt I think it's
a cool shirt the horse looks like it's
having a good time so does the person
riding it I like horses that's the
positive thing I have to say about this
video oh no Stevo getting the blood
choke
a lot of people think in a situation
like this your trachea and your
breathing is what's being blocked off in
reality the bicep muscle and the forearm
muscle putting pressure on the bilateral
carotids and when you put pressure on
the carotids you stop circulation from
reaching the brain as a result you pass
out and you faint this actually is quite
dangerous to do over and over again for
obvious reasons cutting off circulation
to the brain is bad there's also some
things we do in medicine where we
massage like the areas of the neck and
we always say never massage both at the
same time because you could
inadvertently cause this type of side
effect
he's lasting longer than I thought he
would he looks flacy here though I would
stop
oh he looks worried
oh yeah what's up buddy
do you have a wife can we go to Target
first he must be getting some serious
pain meds because that scratch looks
like it hurts remember for most wounds
that are not actively bleeding for like
a mild superficial wound people rush to
put Neosporin or this cream or that
cream just washing it with just some
soap and water you don't even need the
soap just a little cool water and then
covering it with the bandage will allow
it to heal naturally on its own
obviously if you start seeing signs of
infection redness pain in the area you
should go see a doctor get some proper
first aid but on your own just a little
rinse goes a long way
oh this feels dangerous
okay that feels dangerous and the fact
that they're all right behind each other
I feel like something bad's gonna happen
oh no oh no bill
oh
the good part is that they're not
stopping and they're not hitting a hard
surface because inertia is carrying them
and because they're not hitting a hard
surface that reduces the likelihood of
injury but it's still because of their
motion and their speed creates a risk of
like sprains and strains and tears and
things but in terms of like breaking
bones I think the risk drops based on
this type of activity POV wedding day
and the girlies are getting extra B12
shots for that extra boost is that
Gwyneth Paltrow
extra B12 when you have normal B12
levels do not help you get extra boosts
because if the body worked this way we
would just always take extra why would
you ever have low B12 a normal B12 just
live it extra because there's side
effects when there's extra you could
actually develop signs of B12 toxicity
by getting extra B12 shots when you
don't need them this is like my fair to
have a bad day but like honestly it
doesn't even get old
why is she eating butter
no this is a joke no one's eating three
tubs of butter
not only is this I mean everyone's gonna
say this is unhealthy for your heart
because of all the saturated fats in
there and the huge amounts that you're
consuming but also it's gonna create a
really bad stomach ache because you're
going to need very heavy digestive
enzymes in order to break down the
amount of fats you're consuming and when
you can't you're going to have something
known as steadoria if you don't know
what Sierra is the kindest way that I
can put it is fat in your poop do you
want fat in your poop I think not oh
these are so hard yes these are like the
Ninja Warrior exercises oh my God no way
this dude's about to do it
whoa
no way I'm cheering them on let's go
finish no finish
go through I can
just do it Nike
do it
whoa the amount of upper body strength
and coordination and explosiveness that
requires is understated most people
struggle getting a pull-up this guy's
jumping while pulling pull upping
pulling up pulling ups dad reflexes I
almost died at the end
no no that that's not even funny I
understand the joke here but the risk
that causes for your baby who has soft
bones is I would warn the father to
never do that again it's serious like
you could destroy your life by doing
that and you're trying to be funny so
I'm going to show you how to unblock
that stuffy nose go to the top of the
nose to the tip of the nose right in the
middle take these two fingers push it
right in there you're gonna push in and
pull it apart that's difficult use your
thumb push in and pull it apart hold it
there you'll see within 10 seconds your
nose should start to open up this is a
thing that we actually do in osteopathic
medicine called sinus effleurage and we
could actually increase circulation to
the area and help open things up and
move things around obviously it's not a
miracle cure-all but it does feel really
good to massage your sinuses and we
sometimes even do that to uh the cheeks
and then going all the way down uh to
the lymph nodes down here the only real
contraindication where we wouldn't do
this is if you have cancer in the area
we would worry about potential lymphatic
spread but for the average person when
they have like a little infection doing
that for your nasal passageways really
feels good I remember my my dad doing
this to me when I was a kid and I would
literally feel better my nose would
clear out and it's not long-term relief
but you're not really looking for
multi-day Relief if you get a few hours
of a clear nose when you're sick that
feels nice and especially very low risk
broken by a groin why would they allow
that but what happened to a woman if she
ate Sheila jit every day
after 24 hours her energy would increase
as her body is filled with 87 out of 102
minerals what is a 102 minerals I want
to know how many minerals the human body
can have there are 16 different minerals
that are known to be needed in our diets
but this thing gives you 102 okay after
a week she'd notice looser fitting
clothes due to the massive boost in her
metabolism what if she's eating 49
snicker bars while she eats her Sheila
Sheila chip
[Music]
oh wow
that's a magnet pulling out a BB that's
so interesting I wonder why they never
took it out it looks like it's so
superficial it'd be probably an easy
takeout 70 years of working outside but
never leaving the house without pants
that's interesting there's also
definitely some kind of issue with um
bruising maybe potential hematomas from
blood draws and then there's also
potentially some venous insufficiency
which also can be called stasis
dermatitis not diagnosing it but these
are all potential things that would be
on the differential diagnosis
[Music]
wow that's a weird shape for a bicep I
wonder if he's had an injury to that
bicep because it looks like there was a
history of a tear it doesn't look like a
full set of a bicep
what are we looking at here
three babies need a lot of room for
three babies it's a lot of stretching oh
they're so cute you are never going to
have trouble bloating or constipation
again every single trip I go in I bring
a bag of chia seeds and electrolyte I
like chia seeds I like electrolyte
powder it's not going to stop
constipation add water let it sit for 10
minutes appreciate the view and then get
ready to have the best poop of your
entire life okay you're not gonna
when you over promise things and then
they don't deliver you lose trust in an
audience that's why I'm never going to
over promise you anything chia seeds
with a little water and some
electrolytes great I will not say it's
bad there's true legitimate benefit to
having good nutrients like this and if
you're dehydrated especially because
you're on a hike and you're sweating a
lot and it's a hot environment yeah
getting out some electrolytes in may be
ideal but like to say that you have the
best poop of your life that's something
that only an influencer would say it's
not lava on a steak
[Music]
this is kind of
pleasing to watch for some weird reason
isn't that way hotter than like regular
fire
do you think it just destroy the steak
at this point whoa did it like solidify
oh that's the lava
no way it's going to be good on the
inside no it's burnt so crisp the inter
machinations of my mind are an enigma
[Music]
I wonder if you do that with a much
thicker piece of meat would it be as bad
interesting if a woman is obese but she
exercises every day she will outlive the
normal weight woman who doesn't exercise
if you don't exercise you're going to
die sooner what an incredible
generalization you cannot make a
generalization to this degree with any
amount of accuracy so yes someone who
exercises and then someone who doesn't
if you were betting on someone who is
healthier would be the person who
exercises but then putting in other
factors and acting like you know which
weight each factor has on your lifespan
is a little ridiculous these incredible
medical rescues are definitely worth
watching you'll learn a lot and you'll
see some shocking videos click here and
check that out as always stay happy and
Hope
[Music]
thank you